the coronavirus is hitting the travel
industry hard there has also been a
sharp decline in riders on public
transportation in major cities New
York's Metro North is down 48 percent
the Bay Area's BART system saw 35% drop
this week and in Washington DC there
were nearly 100,000 fewer people on the
Metro than one week ago Kris Van Cleave
is at Union Station in DC Chris all
right as worried well good morning
Amtrak has also seen a similar decline I
think it's a mix of concern and the work
from home efforts that are cutting into
ridership but city's view mass transit
in particular as essential it links
people to jobs and services just this
morning New York's MTA tells CBS this
morning it has no plans to suspend or
reduce service at this time but
acknowledges this is a rapidly evolving
situation
in the nation's capital elliegator is
hoping a mask and latex gloves will
protect him from the coronavirus during
his subway ride home no lot of coughing
and hacking blowing on his knees and no
you just got to do whatever the Los
Angeles metro brought us along as crews
use disinfectant to wipe down all the
surfaces riders might touch on every bus
on the entire fleet of train and every
station used by about 1.1 million
Angelenos daily mass transit is very
safe and mass transit is very clean the
nation's busiest mass transit system New
York says it is safe it's now
disinfecting all 741 rail and subway
stations twice a day all subway rail
cars and buses every 72 hours but if you
can get a run around without riding the
subway do it if telecommuting is an
option do it the Washington DC metro has
activated the first two phases of its
pandemic plan are you riding the system
I ride the system daily no concerns I
have no concerns riding the system daily
Theresa amp estado as metros head of
safety individuals should assure that
they are appropriately protecting
themselves through good hand hygiene and
through monitoring their own symptoms
folks should not utilize the system if
they're ill but at this point we don't
think that folks should panic but riders
should take precautions as CBS News
contributor dr. David agus if you're
going to work during rush hour maybe you
want to go to work an hour early when
it's not as busy the key is social
distancing as far away as you can get
from other passengers on mass transit
the better you're going to do
unlike trains and buses airliners cycle
in fresh air every two to four minutes
and use hospital-grade air filters to
separate out bacteria and viruses Gary
Kelly is Southwest CEO we have very
clean airplanes are disinfected and
sanitized every single night very very
thoroughly better than any other mode of
transportation quite frankly and better
than many malls stores etc that you
would visit are you doing things
differently as far as cleaning the
airplane we all knew what
chaos we are we're using different
disinfectants we're doing a more
thorough cleaning of every surface so
that's absolutely more thorough than we
would normally do but it's something
that we feel like we need to be doing in
terms of air travel the latest round of
travel restrictions go into effect at
midnight the president was asked about
the possibility of domestic travel
restrictions
he said that hasn't been talked about
yet but he didn't rule it out Tony got
to consider all scenarios Chris thank
you very much